I was thinking...
You're 17 and you've never had a beer
or any kind of alcohol.
-Of course not.
I'm assuming.
But in the tv show...
The beer bottles are filled with water.
Are your parents proud of you?
Do they think it's fun?
I don't like to talk to my parents
about "Skam".
-Why not?
-It's icky.
-It's...
-Why is it icky?
It's uncomfortable that they think
they see what my life is like
through my character.
How similar is your character to you?
What a hard question. That's mean.
How similar is the character to you?
It's very different. I try to use
some of my charm,
some of my coolness.
Other than that it's very different.
But the problem
is that they think they see
exactly what it's like being young.
Not just me, but what
every young person's life is like.
"Skam" shows what could happen,
not necessarily what happens.
Who were you when you were 16?
What type of person?
I think that's when I discovered music.
In those days you were in a band.
These days you make music
on your computer, but I was in a band.
We played Kurt Cobain.
It was more punk.
Did you know you wanted to do that
for the rest of your life?
Yes, but it was too soon to know.
You don't have to know what you want to be
when you're 16.
There's a lot of pressure
on you these days.
You have to know
what you want to do with your life
-and how to provide for yourself,
where to live.
We didn't think about that.
We were just playing music and having fun.
There's a lot more pressure on you.
Just so you know.
That's not what I meant.
You have that pressure,
but don't let it get to you.
That's what I'm trying to say.
I do think kids of today
are under a lot of pressure.
They have a lot of performance anxiety
and demands.
But don't worry about that. Just have fun.
Thank you for the question.
Us parents have also got secrets.
-You didn't see that coming.
-He doesn't find it interesting.
He doesn't care.
I don't want to hear about it.
It makes me dread growing up.
Excuse me?
Being an adult is amazing.
It gets better.
You get a lot more freedom.
Yeah, but you guys are winning at life.
It's not...
Right?
Say that again.
You are winning at life.
I don't even know what that meant.
My Norwegian isn't great.
He says you've done very well.
You have a job in addition to acting.
-A real job.
-Yes, a real job.
I know you love it. What do you do?
I am a telemarketer. I am.
I'm selling papers.
Aksel, have you had a real job?
-I've been a paperboy.
-There you go.
There's a common theme here.
-I was a telemarketer.
-You were? Really?
-Were you any good?
-Yes.
But I told them not to buy.
That made them want it more.
"You don't need this."
It works.
-Do you want to be an actor?
-Yes.
What kind of role model is he?
I told you, he is winning.
I also want to be winning.
But it might not work out.
Wait a minute.
You don't need a degree
to become an actor.
It's not something he can be.
He is an actor. 100%.
You're an actor in one of the most
successful Norwegian tv shows ever.
Thank you very much.
-You're winning.
-Let's...
You're the main character in season 3,
which starts in Norway shortly.
You were the main character in season 2.
The swedes are getting season one
for Christmas.
So in a couple of months.
Thank you so much for coming.